quiero utilizar este vídeo para
asegurarnos de manera intuitiva y bueno
de cualquier otra forma para asegurarnos
que entendemos la diferencia entre un
estadístico z un estadístico zeta y un
estadístico te lo escribo por acá
estadístico de entonces en muchos de lo
que hemos estado haciendo en esta serie
de vídeos de estadística inferencial
hemos intentado determinar cuál es la
probabilidad de obtener cierta media
muestral verdad entonces lo que hemos
estado haciendo especialmente cuando
tenemos una muestra grande es los
siguientes déjame dibujar una
distribución muestral supongamos que
tenemos una distribución muestral de la
media muestral por aquí y que tiene
cierta media que estamos suponiendo que
tiene y una cierta desviación estándar y
lo que queremos hacer es que cualquier
resultado que obtenemos cualquier
resultado no se supongamos que obtenemos
una media muestral por aquí queremos
determinar la probabilidad de obtener un
resultado al menos tan extremo como este
entonces queremos determinar la
probabilidad de que quede por debajo de
este valor
y eso restárselo a uno
puede encontrar esta área de por aquí
entonces para hacer esto pues
esencialmente estamos preguntándonos
cuántas desviaciones estándar por arriba
de la media estamos la forma en la cual
determinamos eso es tomamos tomamos
nuestra media muestral y ahí le restamos
la media la media muy x barra lo que
creemos que es la media a lo mejor no
sabemos cuál es lo que creemos que es la
media y luego dividimos eso de ahí
dividimos entre la desviación estándar
de la distribución muestral y entre la
desviación estándar de la distribución
muestral esto es cuántas desviaciones
estándar estamos por arriba de la media
ósea esta distancia que marque con la
flecha morada ahora usualmente no
sabemos cuánto vale esto de aquí tampoco
verdad usualmente no lo conocemos pero
para superar esta dificultad utilizamos
el teorema del límite central que nos
dice que suponiendo claro que tenemos
una muestra suficientemente grande esta
expresión de aquí la sigma x barra va a
ser igual a sigma donde sigma es la
desviación estándar pero la desviación
estándar de la población
/ dividido entre la raíz cuadrada del
tamaño de la muestra / raíz de n
entonces esta cosa puede ser reescrita
puede ser descrita como nuestra media
muestral menos la media de nuestra
distribución muestral de la media
muestral dividido entre esta cosa de acá
dividido entre la desviación estándar
poblacional entre la raíz cuadrada del
tamaño de la muestra bueno estoy aquí es
nuestra mejor aproximación de cuántas
desviaciones estándar estamos por arriba
de la media verdad a esta expresión ya
le habíamos llamado el valor z o bien
cuando esto viene de un estadístico de
una media de una muestra entonces a esto
le llamamos un estadístico z y bueno ya
que tenemos esto podemos pues no sé ver
una tabla zeta o de distribución normal
y ya de ahí podemos encontrar la
probabilidad de obtener este valor o uno
más grande entonces esto de ahí nos
daría una cierta probabilidad de obtener
este valor tan extremo y bueno
normalmente cuando hemos hecho esto en
los vídeos pasados pues en los vídeos
pasados tampoco sabemos tampoco sabíamos
perdón pues cuál era la desviación
estándar de la población de nuevo que
para aproximar esa para aproximar la
desviación estándar de la población
decimos que el valor z es
aproximadamente o bien el estadístico z
aproximadamente es igual a aquí va el
mismo numerador otra vez entre y vamos a
aproximar el denominador utilizando la
desviación estándar pero de la muestra
sea ese me voy a poner con otro color
efe que es la desviación estándar de la
muestra y dividimos entre raíz de m
entre raíz del tamaño de la muestra
ahora estoy aquí está bien esto aquí
está ok siempre y cuando siempre y
cuando el tamaño de la muestra sea mayor
que 30 otra forma de pensarlo es que
esta seta de acá va a estar distribuida
normalmente distribuido normalmente
siempre y cuando el tamaño de la muestra
sea de 30 o más recuerda que todo esto
son nada más aproximaciones ahora qué
pasa si el tamaño de la muestra es menor
que 30 o mucho menor que 30 pues
entonces esta expresión ya no va a estar
normalmente de no volver a escribirla
por acá la media muestral menos la media
de la distribución muestral de la media
muestral dividido entre la desviación
estándar de la muestra entre la raíz
cuadrada del tamaño de la muestra
acabamos de decir que si esta cosa es
más grande que 30 o sea el tamaño de la
muestra es 30 o más entonces este valor
este estadístico va a estar distribuido
normalmente pero si no si ésto es
pequeño si la muestra tiene un tamaño
pequeño entonces esto va a tener una
distribución que va a tener una
distribución de y luego pues vamos a
tener que hacer exactamente lo mismo que
acá pero ahora ya no va a ser una
campana normal entonces acá era normal
verdad estoy acá todas las setas estaban
distribuidas normalmente pero acá la
distribución está bueno de hecho más
bien una distribución está normalizada
verdad porque restamos la media entonces
va a ser una distribución de y como es
normalizada va a tener su media en 0 y
lo que vamos a hacer ahorita es
determinar la probabilidad de obtener un
valor t así de extremo
entonces esto de acá estoy acá sería el
valor de que obtenemos y entonces
básicamente calculamos esta área de por
acá
entonces una regla de cabecera muy
sencilla es calcula esta cantidad así y
siempre así es lo primero que tienes que
hacer luego siempre y cuando y esto es
importante siempre y cuando tu muestra
sea de tamaño 30 o más si tienes 30 más
muestras entonces la desviación estándar
de la muestra va a ser una buena
aproximación para la desviación estándar
poblacional así este estadístico se va a
comportar de manera normal y entonces
vas a poder utilizar una tabla zeta para
poder encontrar la probabilidad de
encontrar un valor tan extremo o más
como el que se obtuvo pero si la muestra
tiene un tamaño pequeño entonces el
estadístico esta cantidad de aquí ya no
se va a distribuir normal sino de manera
te va a tener una distribución t y
entonces hay que usar una tabla t para
determinar la probabilidad de obtener un
valor te has y de extremo o más sal y
vamos a ver ejemplos de esto después en
los siguientes vídeos pero espero que
mientras este vídeo te haya ayudado a
entender cuando se utiliza un
estadístico z y cuando se utiliza un
estadístico t